[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
bafin paf un peu exceptionnelle puisque
nous allons essentiellement parler d'un
livre qui s'appelle dont on parle
beaucoup qui s'appelle demeure qui est
de françois xavier
bellamy pour en parler anne-charlotte
bezina bonjour if l'enseigné toujours
voilà et jean baptiste duclair aussi à
vous enseigner tout noir de versailles
saint quentin est un jeu là rien ne
change notre m
je vais vous faire une confidence
stéphane rousseau est toujours
professeur à l'université wits
versailles saint quentin
oui et 2 accueillons françois-xavier bel
habit bonjour merci d'être avec nous
merci pour eux alors je présente
rapidement vous êtes philosophe est
normalien vous êtes agrégé de philo
enseigne est toujours là filou fait même
je crois mais je suis très intimidant
d'être devant cette impasse
d'universitaires défenseur du secondaire
je vais baisser mais je crois que vous
faites deux lundis par mois des soirées
philo dans cette annonce a eu du succès
exactement c'est vrai qu'il ya une vraie
est une vraie attente aujourd'hui en
tous les cas la philosophie et les ponts
sans doute un besoin le besoin qu'on a
deux de s'arrêter un instant de
réfléchir de se poser les questions qui
traversent nos vies et donc les soirées
de la philo c'est tous les lundis soirs
au théâtre saint-georges d'accord et
paris ont fini par y habulin des
williams
il ya vraiment un public fidèle et
assidu et c'est quoi vous faites des
conférences ou sait enfin où des gens
posent des questions il ya des thèmes
c'est un cycle de conférences alors il
ya une série de conférences sur des
questions
on a travaillé depuis le début d'année
existe-t-il une vérité est ce que tous
passent la prochaine fois c'est sûr
peut-on être sûr de ne pas se tromper
et puis en alternance un cycle de
conférences sur les hauteurs pour
emmener les gens qui viennent ou ceux
qui nous regardent en ligne d'ailleurs
ce qu'on peut aussi participer en vidéo
en différé donc emmener les gens passer
une soirée avec platon une soirée avec
aristote et la prochaine soirée avec
marc aurèle il est temps de redécouvrir
des auteurs qui sont toujours d'une
grande actualité en fait il ya donc une
vraie un vrai besoin de réflexion pas
oui c'est certain je suis d'ailleurs
très intimidée impressionné de voir que
des gens qui ont passé une longue
journée de travail viennent devraient
consacrer une heure et demie de leur
temps à ma sur un enseignement parce
qu'en réalité c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment là c'est donc le lundi soir à
20h30 d'orge et puis maintenant dans une
trentaine de villes où des groupes se
sont désistés succès à distance
voilà c'est variable comme comme succès
alors vous êtes vous avez parallèlement
une activité politique puisque vous êtes
adjoint au maire de versailles la mairie
de versailles
et puis vous publier ce livre demeure
dont on parle énormément je regarde fait
la une du figaro magazine
alors voilà on dit beaucoup d'articles
dans lesquels on dit enfin la droite qui
était un peu déboussolé en plein doute à
trouver ces fonds servent à près tout ça
je mets présentés très brièvement le le
livre et puis après or on va en parler
le livre s'ouvre sur une lettre de
saint-exupéry on est en quart en trois
dans la nuit de 43 il craint au fond là
la victoire des nazis il pose cette
question si jamais ils gagnent que
peut-on dire que faut-il dire aux hommes
et c'est à cette question que vous
répondez dans ce livre alors il ya
d'abord une sorte de fête les festivités
vont reconstituer un peu une histoire du
mouvement d'héraclite on ne se baigne
jamais deux fois dans le même fleuve à
galilée qui a montré que la terre
n'était pas au centre de l'univers
et évidemment avec toutes les
conséquences que ce que cette découverte
va
à voir et au fond vous en tirer une
certaine confusion sur ce qu'est la
modernité jusqu'à jusqu'ici au procès
que la modernité au fond c'est et or la
raison et vous dit bah non c'est pas ça
c'est plutôt la passion du mouvement la
passion du du changement avec toutes les
conséquences que cela peut avoir sur le
plan politique évidemment c'est vrai que
si on regarde tous les slogans les
présidentielles c'est le changement de
juillet ou le changement sur le plan
économique avec la consommation
peut-être assure consommation il faut
toujours avoir le dernier écran plat ou
le dernier iphone sur le plan éthique
est ce que on va pouvoir résister à ce
que la technique nous nous propose sur
le plan de la religion qui vous apparaît
parfois comme une barrière au
développement individuel donc c'est tout
ces conseils qu'on cela que vous tirez
dans ce passionnant nouvelle définition
c'est peu dire de de la modernité une
passion du mouvante pas sûr du
changement et à ça vous vous opposez
peut-être des valeurs auxquelles on
pourrait se référer notre demeure
c'est-à-dire habiter le monde
voilà on regarde on peut-être un certain
nombre de valeurs du passé alors je pose
une première question puis après on en
débat tous mais si aux fouilles et cette
passion du changement est ce que c'est
pas parce que les les justement ce qu'on
a gardé n'est pas formidable
à mon sens c'est l'inversé qui se
produit dans nos consciences c'est à
dire que parce que nous sommes
passionnés du changement parce que nous
voulons que tout change
nous finissons par regarder ce que nous
avons entre les mains comme n'étant pas
formidable c'est parce que nous sommes
convaincus que ce qui viendra demain est
forcément meilleure que ce qui existe
aujourd'hui que nous finissons par nous
dire que ce qui existe aujourd'hui n'est
pas d'un an malgré un immense alors
qu'en réalité si on y regarde bien on
devrait pouvoir reconnaître que ce que
nous avons dans les mains ce que nous
avons reçu ce qui nous a été transmis
par ceux qui nous ont précédés ce que
nous n'avons pas produit nous mêmes tout
cela a aussi une valeur infinie
prenons la question de l'écologie par
exemple qui habite aujourd'hui notre
inquiétude collective à raison
d'ailleurs bien pendant pendant quelques
décennies
nous sommes ouverts aux promesses de la
technique de la technologie avec la
certitude que cette espèce de vieille
nature limitée est finie qui pouvait
constituer une sorte de bain
le pénible à l'expression de nos désirs
allait enfin être dépassé par les
prodiges delà de la technique et de
notre propre pouvoir
et bien aujourd'hui nous nous rendons
compte qu'en réalité cette nature avec
toutes ses limites elle avait évidemment
sa nécessité et que nous avons perturbé
quelque chose qui était magnifique et
qui était nécessaire même à la
préservation de la vie quelqu'un me
disait l'autre jour
rendez vous compte c'est une chance
fabuleuse avec la technique je peux
manger les fruits que j'aime en
n'importe quelle saison à n'importe quel
moment
oui mais en réalité l'expression là avec
cette révolte contre la nature et ses
rythmes propres et sa lenteur et fait
résistance avec cette révolte là nous
avons perturbé la nature aujourd'hui
nous redécouvrons cas peut-être une
forme de sagesse à se laisser à se
laisser éclairer par la nature et à
recevoir d'elle quelque chose qui mérite
d'être suivie et d'être respectés être
protégés de demeurer en quelque sorte
oui alors moi mais alors tout d'abord
j'ai eu grand plaisir à vous lire à
retrouver dans votre manière de nous
présenter une brève histoire comme vous
l'avez dit du mouvement les les moments
de jeunesse autour du monde de sophie où
nous rencontrons un chacun des
philosophes on aaron pas simplement avec
chacun d'eux et vous parliez des soirées
avec marc aurèle j'ai passé beaucoup
donné avec on s'en doute en ce sens le
sceau du dixel le demande parce que
c'est vrai que vous explique ce très
très bien et très clairement enfin tout
à fait si c'est vrai qu'on suive une
forme d'histoires avec cela qui
finalement tourne toujours autour de
votre finalité qui est de démontrer que
justement nous sommes à la recherche
d'une finalité qu'à votre sens il en
faut une pour mettre fin au mouvement
pour le mouvement s'est un petit peu
donc votre postulat mois
sur l'ouvragé évidemment beaucoup de
questions mais il y en a surtout une qui
me qui m'a intéressé c'est comment
concrètement notamment par rapport à
votre parcours qui est à la fois le
parcours d'un homme d'un philosophe et
d'un homme politique
est ce que concrètement comment est ce
que vous arrivez à appliquer ce vous
parlait parfois de contemplation
justement ont commencé à être
contemplatif où être justement à contre
courant de l'avenir ou en tout cas de ce
progrès sans cesse dans votre vie
concrète d'hommes et d'hommes politiques
et de philosophes c'est une belle
question une question très personnelle
est très difficile aussi parce que parce
que de fait c'est une forte une forme de
lutte va nous avons tous en réalité
alors être d'abord jeu même si les mais
il arrive que les médias me consacre
ainsi je ne prétends pas philosophe et
surtout le plus important c'est de bien
comprendre que nous sommes tous appelés
à le devenir d'une serre derrière c'est
à dire à incarner aussi dans notre vie
ce à quoi nous tenons et ce que nous
essayons de penser et j'ai essayé de
faire effectivement oeuvre de pédagogie
pour rendre à tous les lecteurs ce qui
leur appartient au fond c'est à dire
cette histoire de la pensée qui est
aussi une manière de redécouvrir nos
vies et une fois qu'on a re découvert un
ovi justement on peut retrouver une
forme de maîtrise sur elle et c'est ce
qui nous manque le plus au fond je suis
sûr que beaucoup de ceux qui nous
écoutent ont comme moi le sentiment que
nous sommes devenus les jouets de notre
propre pouvoir et que les outils que
nous serions censés maîtriser en réalité
nous maîtrise et je suis le premier à le
vivre dans ma propre vie je crois mais
c'est une question immense que c'est
toujours au fond une époque qui produit
la technique qui accompagne sa
conception du monde que pour le dire
autrement nous ne sommes pas fasciné par
l'immédiateté parce que nous avons des
smartphones dans nos poches mais que
c'est parce que nous sommes fascinés par
l'immédiateté que nous allons des
smartphones dans nos poches
cela étant dit il transforme aussi notre
rapport au monde et une fois que nous
les avons dans nos poches et bien nous
sommes en permanence
habité par cette tension vers
l'accélération et il devient difficile
de leur résister pour recréer un espace
pour cet effort de contemplation vous
évoquez à l'instant je crois que s'il ya
un vrai défi aujourd'hui pour chacun
d'entre nous pour ceux qui nous écoutent
et je me l'appliqué moi le premier
c'est de réussir à retrouver la maîtrise
de notre propre pouvoir réussir à
retrouver la maîtrise de nos propres
vies et donc de recréer des espaces de
temps dans nos journées dans nos
semaines pour prendre le temps de lire
de s'asseoir de s'arrêter de réfléchi de
s'interroger mais au fond dedans on voit
bien que la lecture est une activité
menacée en tant que tel dans l'écologie
de nos vies pourrait-on dire elle est
pourtant absolument nécessaire si
j'avais une réponse à vous faire ce
serait ce soit celle là je crois que le
vrai défi y est le vrai remède en même
temps c'est la lecture je pourrais citer
d'autres
d'autres lieux de ces des joueurs de
contemplation kikim son plus personnel
je pense à la voile par exemple je suis
un passionné de voile et c'est vraiment
pour moi une manière magnifique de c'est
une façon de cette façon de bouger
vraiment mais c'est très intéressant
c'est un mouvement mais c'est un
mouvement qui est habité par un but au
fond tous ceux qui pratiquent la
navigation savent que quand on navigue
on peut lutter contre les éléments mais
on lutte contre les éléments pour
avancer pour faire son chemin au milieu
d'un monde qui est perpétuellement
mobile pour pouvoir avancer vers un port
oui on a vu tu n'étais pas d'araignée le
mouvement mais au contraire de lui
redonner un sens c'est ce qui c'est vrai
que je suis vont prendre une image afin
que d'autres prises facile quand on vous
dit voilà on a l'impression club
aujourd'hui c'est une sorte de cyclistes
comme ça il peut pas s'arrêter parce
qu'ici c'est la petite tombe mais qui
sait pas où il va en gros c'est ça oui
alors en réalité voilà émerveillement
mais ce qu'il ya de magnifiques dans le
tour de france c'est le c'est l'arrivée
c'est l'arrivée voyez vous pouvez lutter
pendant des heures sur votre vélo mais
tout cela a un sens parce qu'à la fin il
ya une ligne d'arrivée et que c'est ce à
quoi vous tendez serrano sens qu'il me
manque aujourd'hui c'est la ligne
moi je vais à charlene a résumé mais
pour pour développer juger ce que j'ai
le plus apprécié dans cet ouvrage c'est
en effet le caractère très pédagogique
ensemble on sent le pédagogue elle est
le même les profs sont contents
j'avoue dit pourquoi parce que parce que
je crois avoir compris et je me dis mais
l'auteur a fait a fait plus que
correctement son travail puis le lecteur
dans mesure de le comprendre
je crois avoir compris et je trouve que
ce ce début avec syntec c'est cette fin
avec l'odyssée fadjri que je vous dise
veut dire je me disais mais à saint-ex
c'est pas mal mais l'odyssée moi il me
semblait que ça c'est vrai ce serait
encore mieux parce que on revient à un
service complètement leur tour mais
voilà c'est à la fin de nos morts voilà
on connaît le nom du meurtrier à la fin
au delà je trouve qu'il a cet ouvrage un
peu le défaut de sa qualité éminente à
savoir lorsqu'on s'engage dans une
démarche pédagogique j'ai le sentiment
que on opère une sorte de mise en
contraste pour que ces contrastes soit
plus saisissable soit visible et je
crois que cela fait partie de l'art
pédagogique et c'est vrai que jusqu'à là
à peu près la moitié de votre ouvrage
je me suis dit mais quel regard l'auteur
porte-t-il sur sur le monde
je ne me sens pas fasciné par le
mouvement perpétuel et je crois que je
ne suis pas le seul je me sens en
situation assez fréquentes d'aptitude à
faire une pause
contempler alors je moi je suis
passionné de montagne
alors c'est un autre mouvement un
mouvement d'un autre type avec un but
que je que je trouve magnifique c'est à
dire un but qui ne sert à rien de gravir
un sommet ça ne sert à rien parce
qu'après on redescend et la descente en
général est bien plus exténué mais cela
ne me gêne pareil pour moi je trouve que
cette allégorie montagnarde de résume un
peu ma conception de la visible il n'y a
pas de but enfin je suis assez camus non
dans ce dans cette vision des choses
mais ça me dérange absolument pas d'
alors que le parcours mérite à lui
souhaite d'être accompli et donc voyez
ces sept
ce contraste
trop fort de mon point de vue qui m'a
fait dire pendant la première moitié de
ma lecture mais mais bon sens enfin ça
ça n'est pas que cela
il y as autour de moi autour de nous
bien des individus qui sont déjà
conscients que justement cette ère du
mouvement ont perçu à la fin vous le
dites après vous nuancé j'aime plutôt la
nuance ce mouvement perpétuel a suscité
une sorte de contre mouvement au fond
tout ce qui alors je pensais aussi en
vous lisant à des auteurs que j'avais
beaucoup aimé que j'avais étudié dans le
cadre de tout ce qui concerne la
délibération le le rythme politique
quelqu'un comme hartmut rosa par exemple
comme paul virilio les philosophes de
l'accélération mais tout cela a suscité
alors ce qu on a appelé cela est fait
mode peut-être parler de la mode de
manière très très incisive et très
convaincante le une sorte de slow life
de slow food de ce bond de réactions
directement bénéficié semble-t-il mais
j'ai autour de moi des gens qui par
exemple il y en a peu mais j'en connais
qui veulent pas prendre le tgv
si on peut faire le même parcours avec
un train-corail ils prennent le train
corail parce que dr après maintenant et
je me mets vraiment je me flatte de les
connaître
je donc vous avez deux deux ou trois
moments où vous nous on s'est quand même
en disant oui la vie ce n'est pas que
cela ce n'est pas qu'un mouvement
perpétuel
mais voyez ses 7,7 millions contraste
très très radicale mais très pédagogique
en même temps qui moi m'a
gêné non non et m'a vraiment vraiment
marqué merci beaucoup c'est comme en
direct de toute façon comme vous le
disiez c'était un défi intenable c'est à
dire que je ne prétends pas être un
universitaire et j'ai j'admire beaucoup
la vocation universitaire je me suis
toujours sentie attirée par le travail
très particulier consiste à aller en
quelque sorte sur le sur le sur le seuil
pour pouvoir partager vous savez que
dans la grèce antique les les savants
faisait les cours et au tehrik le matin
pour l'heure leurs élèves leurs
disciples et l'après midi et les cours
exotérique pour le tout venant qui est
voilà je suis plutôt aux territoires par
caractère je suis plutôt attaché à cet
exercice pédagogique mais dont je
reconnais parfaitement le l'humilité la
modestie et et pour pouvoir faire une
histoire intellectuelle digne de ce nom
qui viendraient évoquer cette histoire
du mouvement comme il le faudrait il
aurait fallu des centaines de deux pages
des milliers de pages ça n'était pas
tout à fait mon objet ce qui est vrai
aussi dans ce que vous dites c'est que
bien sûr je ne suis pas le seul à
éprouver cette lassitude de cet
épuisement intérieur devant ce mouvement
dans lequel malgré tout nous sommes
collectivement embarqués et il est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui d'aider d'autres
réactions se manifeste aussi bien sur le
terrain intellectuel que dans la vie
pratique et et nous sommes nombreux à le
ressentir
mais malgré tout ce que j'ai tenté de
penser c'est non pas d'abord une
question individuelle et j'allais dire
moral mais une question collective et
d'une certaine manière politique non pas
au sens d'un parti ou d'une
d'un travail de non biologique mais
politique au sens où il s'agit pour nous
de penser un problème collectif
est ce cette question du mouvement est
un problème collectif aussi bien
d'ailleurs dans l'ordre politique que
dans l'ordre économique
quelque chose me frappe et vous le
rappeliez tout à l'heure c'est que dans
le monde ancien dans le monde classique
dans le monde romain par exemple on
n'aurait jamais été élu en promettant le
changement
l'essentiel de la politique c'était de
sauver ce qu'il veut et pour pour pour
nous aujourd'hui
vous ne pouvez pas avoir la moindre
chance de prétendre être élu si vous
promettez de la devrait conserver les
choses en quelques d'ailleurs le mot
même de conservation est devenu
quasiment une occasion de prendre sur le
terrain politique et c'est très
intéressant de voir que du point de vue
des structures de penser nous sommes
entrés depuis je crois la chute du mur
de berlin c'est à dire depuis
l'effondrement des grandes idéologies
dans une sorte de mouvement qui ne se
connaît plus de destinations et nos
responsables publics aussi bien
d'ailleurs que nos chefs d'entreprise
qui parle sans arrêt d'adaptation
d'agilité de transformation serait bien
incapable de nous dire vers où nous nous
dirigeons et à quel endroit nous
pourrions nous dire voilà nous sommes
arrivés vous prenez l'exemple de la
montagne mais la montagne n'est pas un
mouvement sans but justement vous montez
vers le feriez vous ne montez pas
indéfiniment et d'ailleurs une montée en
définit comme une descente indéfini
parce que la descente elle aussi à un
but c'est le chalet vers lequel on
dirige c'est la chaleur de la maison que
l'on va pouvoir retrouver via la montée
comme la descente ont un sens parce
qu'elle se dirige vers un point
d'arrivée et il me semble qu'aujourd'hui
ce qui nous manque ce n'est pas donc en
droit de pouvoir arrêter le mouvement au
figer les choses se crisper dans une
forme de de lenteur qui vaudrait pour
elle-même elle aussi mais c'est de
retrouver le sommet vers lequel nous
allons ensemble le sens et que ceux qui
nous dirigent puisse de nouveau nous
dire voilà nous nous sommes confrontés à
des changements très importants très
difficile très exigeant mais c'est pour
aller ici et c'est là que nous pourrons
nous dire enfin voilà nous sommes nous
sommes arrivés quelque part je redis
effectivement le la difficulté elle est
peut-être là c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il ya ce mouvement que
vous évoquez vous n'êtes pas contre le
mouvement
vous êtes contre un mouvement qui n'a
pas de but voilà et vient à lui même son
propre but tant que dirigeant même sens
propre vie mais alors le la difficulté
elle est de savoir quel est ce but à
proprement parler puisque finalement si
on fait le départ entre ce qui doit
changer et ce qui ne doit pas changer
certains verront pour un objet donné
une incitation changement là où d'autres
considérons justement qu'il ne faut pas
que ça change précisément parce que le
but n'est pas le même et moi j'attendais
un petit peu de la philosophie justement
cette axiologie des valeurs c'est-à-dire
qu'elle doit être ce but qu'elle doit
être cet objectif alors récité le
réchauffement climatique
vous citez un moment où si je crois la
procréation par l'homme et la femme
mais il n'y a pas à part ces deux
éléments qui qui en tout cas pour le
premier rassemble je pense la plupart
des français qui prennent pour vrai
l'effet sur sur la question du
changement climatique
il n'y a pas véritablement de définition
de la fin du but vers lequel nous devons
aller le bonheur sur la vérité sur sur
ces choses là
et du coup je me demandais si ce n'était
pas propre à mais là vous me reprendre
et 6,6 d'une bêtise à la manière dont
vous engagez finalement vos deux
activités celle de philosophes et celle
d'hommes politiques et j'ai le sentiment
finalement que vous réservez la
philosophie vous enlevez finalement la
philosophie ce qui peut se rapprocher de
la politique c'est à dire en fait la
définition des valeurs du vivre ensemble
que vous réserver uniquement finalement
à votre action politique donc voilà je
voulais voir comment vous articuler ces
deux activités des activités ce qui est
certain c'est que je je je je comprends
parfaitement l'objection que vous faites
et d'une sage manière elle correspond
aussi au projet de ce livre je n'ai pas
voulu fixer un but ça aurait été
infiniment prétentieux de ma part mais
simplement montré que nous avions besoin
d'en retrouver un et c'est déjà d'une
certaine manière un acquis fondamental
il me semble que de fait à la fois dans
nos vies personnelles nous sommes
ouverts à une liberté qui fait que
chacun d'entre nous regardera
différemment le point d'arrivée auquel
il se destine et dans notre vie
collective
c'est toute la noblesse et toute la
nécessité de l'activité politique que de
mettre sur la place publique le débat
autour de ce qui doit ou non changer de
ce que nous devons ou non transformé de
ce vers quoi nous nous dirigeons
collectivement et rien ne remplacera de
ce point de vue là le débat démocratique
parce que il n'y a pas d'évidence des
buts
rien n'est rien et absolument évident
dans ce monde de clair-obscur d'en
parler aristote et dans lequel nous
dirigeons-nous mouvement il nous faut
discuter ensemble pour pouvoir fixer ce
cap dans le l'horizon qui nous attend et
ce qui est ce qui me terrifiait
aujourd'hui sur le plan politique c'est
l'idée que le débat pourrait se résumer
à une opposition entre ceux qui veulent
avancer et ceux qui ne veulent pas
avancer
entre ceux qui veulent le mouvement et
ceux qui au contraire veulent arrêter le
mouvement
entre ceux qui veulent aller de l'avant
et ceux qui voudraient revenir en
arrière comme si l'avant et l'arrière
était d'une certaine manière déjà défini
comme si le but était fixé d'avancé
comme si le progrès par exemple
s'imposer d'évidence ce que j'ai tenté
de l'entrée dans ce livre c'est
simplement que le progrès ce que nous
appelons progrès n'a rien d'une évidence
et qu'il faut précisément que nous
puissions en discuter ensemble et c'est
là que se joue la nécessité démocratique
par exemple vous parler de la question
de la procréation on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une question qui
anime le débat public qui va animer
pendant quelques quelques mois quelques
années sans doute la question est est ce
que par exemple le fait de de technicité
de plus en plus la procréation est ce
que c'est un progrès est ce qu'une
innovation technique est nécessairement
un progrès bien je ne le crois pas et
c'est pour cette raison que nous devons
en parler ensemble n'y a pas d'un côté
des gens qui sont favorables au progrès
et qui sont capables d'accepter l'avenir
et qui vont joyeusement vers l'avant et
d'autres personnes au contraire qui sont
pessimistes et rétrograde et qui sont
incapables d'avancer et qui veulent
revenir
en arrière il ya simplement une question
fondamentale qui nous est posée à nous
tous et qui est qu'est-ce qui est
vraiment un progrès vers quoi est ce que
nous voulons nous diriger et de ce point
de vue-là il s'agit pas de deux de
réfléchir à ce qui dans le passé mérite
d'être conservé mais à ce qu'il vaut
d'une certaine manière de façon fixe est
stable comme des points fixes qui
peuvent vraiment donner sens à notre
marche
prenons prenons la question de la
justice puisque je sais que je parle
avec des juristes la définition de la
justice en tant que telle elle varie
dans le temps parce que nos conceptions
changer parce que nos représentations
évolué mais la justice elle-même elle
ce que je crois profondément avec toute
mon expérience philosophique c'est que
la justice elle même elle ne change pas
je veux dire par là que l' esclavage par
exemple a toujours été injuste que même
quand toute l'humanité pratique l
esclavage
cette pratique était profondément
contraire à la dignité de l'être humain
petit à petit nous avons mûri et nous
avons cheminé nous avons progressé parce
que nous nous sommes rapprochés de cet
idéal de justice qui en tant que telle
et éternelle et c'est là que le savant
le philosophe et le politique recherche
en même temps quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre de l'éternité alors oui ça pour
le coup j'ai essayé de le déterminer un
peu dans ce livre c'est à dire que le
savent on cherche la vérité le politique
cherche la justice
nous cherchons tous ensemble le bien le
bonheur et tout cela ce sont des choses
qui en tant que telle ne sont pas du
tout de l'ordre de l'évidence et qui
mérite d'être recherché petit à petit
par la délibération collective mais qui
sont en revanche des points fixes qui
dans leur éternel actualité valent
encore pour nous et qui peuvent redonner
sens au changement que nous voulons nous
imposer aujourd'hui
alors parlons peut-être concrètement de
certains problèmes
vous avez abordé exemple la pma ou la
gpa dans quelques années ça sera le lait
la question du transhumanisme
équipe qui va se poser vous vous dites
au fond on peut on doit pouvoir résister
au progrès que nous propose la technique
on sait ça va on pour nous en tout cas
on peut débattre de ce que la technique
nous propose est peut-être peut-être
refusé de s'y soumettre
est ce que vous êtes penser que si
simple que ça après tout ça ouvre des
perspectives énormes inde et des gens
qui ne pouvaient pas jusque là par
exemple avoir d'enfant et qui peuvent
avoir aujourd'hui grâce à ces techniques
donc forcément il va y avoir recours non
alors c'est là que le débat proprement
politique commence d'abord je crois et
cite même chose très importante
je crois qu'il n'y a pas de progrès
technique il y à des innovations
techniques mais toute innovation
technique n'est pas nécessairement avec
et le progressisme si c'était le progrès
de l'autre d'accord il a l'idée du
progressisme c'est plutôt l'idée que
tout changement est à toute innovation
n'est pas nécessairement un progrès est
d'ailleurs ce que nous avons appelé
progrès pendant des années s'est avéré
en fait avoir été par certains égards de
formidable régression parfois prenant la
question de l'agriculture
aujourd'hui nous sommes tout heureux de
découvrir le bio de découvrir les
circuits courts de découvrir une
agriculture durable
en réalité nous appelons progrès ce qui
ressemble à l'agriculture traditionnelle
alors que pendant quelques décennies le
progrès a été de toute évidence on érige
maintenant l'agriculture intensive la
mécanisation les produits chimiques
tout cela était le programme est donc il
faut se garder surtout de croire qu'il
ya des progrès techniques en tant que
tel il ya des innovations techniques qui
peuvent être des progrès mais qui
peuvent aussi ne pas l'être mais c'est
le cas notamment dans la question de
cette technicisation effectivement il
assure la vie alors bien sûr elle répond
à des désirs qui sont en tant que tel
parfaitement légitime et parfaitement
respectable mais la question qui nous
est posée et là encore collectivement il
s'agit pas d'un débat moral ou
individuelles la question qui nous est
posée collectivement c'est est ce que
c'est vraiment un progrès de fer que le
désir devienne la norme de nos
transformation que le flux infini du
désir et nous savons qu'il est infini
parce que nous le vivons dans nos
propres vies je veux dire par là que la
société de consommation nous a
suffisamment montré qu' aucun délit
on ne pouvait lorsqu'il était comble et
mettre fin de façon définitive à la
région mécanique du désert au mouvement
perpétuel de ce plaisir est bien est ce
que est ce que appliquée à la politique
appliquée à la vie elles mêmes
cette norme d'un mouvement infini du
désir est ce que c'est vraiment un
progrès pour ma part je ne le crois pas
mais c'est là que le débat commence
vraiment mais c'est peut-être progrès
pour certaines personnes bien sûr
aujourd'hui certaines personnes
considérées comme en cause les regards
par les dommages et moi on a parlé tout
à l'heure aussi de vous avez parlé de la
justice comme étant pour vous vous
donnez peut d'ailleurs de vos valeurs
absolues que vous que vous citez en fin
d'ouvragé et je crois que vous mettez la
justice et la vérité notamment à ce
titre là moi il m'a semblé que dans
cette grande histoire des idéologies
vous avez peut-être au mit vous parlez
de la liberté vous parlez de la justice
on parlait peu de l'égalité et
finalement moi j'ai le sentiment que ce
progrès technologique ou quand on parle
de la gpao la pma au même quand on parle
de plusieurs luttes politiques ou de
lutte de droit finalement ce que les
français en particulier mais ce que les
êtres humains vont souhaiter c'est plus
d'égalité dont moi je me suis demandé
s'il y avait pas une demeure à deux
vitesses c'est à dire que on pourrait se
dire que on a envie de demeurer et de
contempler quand on est heureux de sa
condition mais que quelque part ce désir
de changement il peut être un besoin
aussi suivant si on peut ou pas
sciemment demeurer dans sa condition et
c'est cette quête d'égalité c'est
vouloir plus parce qu'on n'a pas à celle
où parce qu'on n'a pas la même chose que
que certains autres qui eux peuvent se
permettre de demeurer
c'est une question que je me suis posée
à vous lire alors c'est effectivement
une réflexion très très intéressante le
le concept d'égalité la recherche
d'égalité elle a un sens quand elle est
articulée justement à l'exigence de
justice et bien sûr elle correspond à
cette exigence il serait totalement
anormal que l'inégalité soit instituée
comme quelque chose qui doit se
prolonger éternellement sur le mode
d'une sorte de reproduction
aristocratique des privilèges
cela étant dit il faut bien concevoir
que nous parlons ici de notre condition
humaine à tous
et je je je suis assez effrayés là
encore de l'idée que dans ce débat qui
s'engage
il s'agirait de priver certaines
personnes de droits que d'autres
posséderait pour ma part je suis
célibataire je n'ai pas d'enfant
j'aimerais avoir des enfants
de la même manière dans la question de
la pma aujourd'hui il est question
d'ouvrir est la pma aux couples de
femmes aux femmes seules parce qu'elle
éprouve ce désir je le comprends
parfaitement ce désir il est totalement
légitime
la question qui nous est posée mais par
est ce que chacun à égalité a le droit
d'avoir des enfants
ce serait d'ailleurs complètement
absurde parce que nous reconnaîtrions
tous ensemble que certaines personnes à
certains âges de la vie par exemple ne
peuvent pas accéder à ce droit à
l'enfant voyez il ya quelque chose qui
touche aussi à une forme de
d'aberrations cette logique de l'égalité
poussé jusqu'au bout elle n'aurait
finalement aucun sens
la question qui nous est posée et
faut-il que la technique nous servent à
vaincre les limites que la nature impose
de manière douloureuse à nos propres
désirs et de fait nous avons tous des
désirs que la nature laissant satisfait
nous prenons le premier d'entre eux bien
sûr aucun d'entre nous n'a envie de
mourir est la mort est évidemment
quelque chose que nous subissons comme
une fatalité douloureuse la mort est de
toute évidence l'une de ses grandes
frontières qui s'impose à nous et que
nous l'avons pas décidé et par laquelle
nous passerons malgré nous parce que
personne ne veut mourir est bien la
question qui nous est posée et ce n'est
pas une question de droit ou d'égalité
c'est d'abord une question qui touche à
notre capacité d'habiter ce monde dans
les frustrations qu'il nous impose ses
vrais d'habiter nos corps dans les
limites qu'ils constituent pour nous et
dans les limites douloureuse encore une
fois c'est vrai il faut le reconnaître
absolument il s'agit pas de dire je suis
content de ce que j'ai donc je reste là
non je souffre évidemment de ses limites
mais est-ce que nous avons quelque chose
à gagner dans le fait de vouloir aller
toujours au delà de ses limites que la
nature nous présente
juste une précision vaut pour que les
choses soient bien que vous défendez au
fond est-ce que vous défendez vous dites
voilà la nature nous impose un certain
nombre de choses il faut respecter les
lois de la nature
c'est quand même on est quand même dans
un c'est un peu l'horreur aussi des
doigts de la nature s'est passé pas que
le bien de l'om
encore une fois il sait il ya vraiment
quelque chose d'éprouvants dans la
condition humaine dans la réalité
naturelle
attention je ne dis pas par là qu'il
faut être opposé à la technique à la
technologie d'antenne la médecine par
exemple la mêlant soul humilité c'est
aussi la lutte contre les lois de la
nature
non mais une lutte contre les lois de la
nature pour pouvoir d'une certaine
manière les les justement les préserver
si on prend la question de la médecine
etc
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que les jeunes
médecins qui étudient juste à côté d'eux
de nous à la halle et us q qu'est-ce
qu'ils étudient mais ils étudient ce
qu'on appelle la santé et la santé c'est
un certain équilibre décor et un
équilibre naturel par exemple nous
sommes tous nés avec deux bras avec de
gens mais il arrive que certains du fait
d'un handicap ou du fait d'un accident
de la vie n'est qu'un seul bras par
exemple le rôle de la médecine c'est y
compris par des prouesse technologique
incroyable de faire en sorte qu'ils
puissent retrouver usage de leurs deux
bras ça c'est de la médecine
alors vous allez dire évidemment qu'il
ya une forme de lutte contre la nature
et c'est vrai parce que il ya quelque
chose de la tuque là de donner corps à
une intervention dans les corps mais
mais pour pouvoir retrouver cet
équilibre naturel qu'on appelle la santé
l'offensé est aussi ce qui se joue dans
la procréation médicalement assistée
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui la
procréation médicalement assistée c'est
vous avez vous avez un couple avec un
homme et une femme qui n'arrive pas à
avoir d'enfant parce qu'il ya une
infertilité qui est pathologique c'est à
dire une maladie ou un accident de la
vie qui fait qu' il leur est impossible
d'avoir des enfants or la santé veut que
l'union du masculin et du féminin s'est
pas seulement dans le dans l'expérience
humaine c'est dans mon tout le vivant
que l'union du masculin et du féminin
engendre la vie est donc là si cette
infertilité pathologique est constatée
on peut recourir à un acte médical qui
va rétablir la santé ou bien qui va
imiter la santé en faisant que un enfant
puisse naître mais il en va tout
autrement lorsque encouragé par le fait
que la nature peut être trouvé son jeu
mais dès qu'on peut me donner un
un deuxième bras qui me manquent si je
retourne voir un chirurgien en lui
disant maintenant je voudrais avoir un
troisième bras ça me serait extrêmement
utile je fais quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre de la technique à peu près
identique mais qui est totalement
différent en fait dans la nature de
l'acte c'est à dire qu'il s'agit
maintenant d'un acte technique qui vient
contraindre la nature à donner ce que
ordinairement elle ne nous procure
jamais et c'est ça qu'on appelle le
transhumanisme vous voyez que c'était
pour dans quelques années mais entre ses
mains c'est maintenant parce que je mène
ce qu'on appelle à mon avis improprement
l'ouverture de la procréation
médicalement assistée à des femmes
seules ou à des couples de femmes c'est
exactement du même ordre que l'idée que
voilà à partir de cette expérience qui
fait que nous pouvons retrouver un
deuxième bras qui nous manque
grâce à la médecine nous allons en
demander un troisième c'est à dire que
lorsqu'une femme seule va aller voir le
même médecin pour lui demander de
pouvoir avoir un enfant eh bien elle
sera dans cette logique qui n'est plus
celle d'une réparation de l' équilibre
naturel de nos corps mais au contraire
d'une violation de cet équilibre naturel
parce que jamais un corps en bonne santé
seul ne peut donner la vie et donc c'est
une question qui nous concerne tous et
pas du tout il s'agit pas de priver
certains d'un droit il s'agit de
réfléchir à la question de savoir ses 5
au fond les jours puisque enfin on nous
ça nous ajoute un droit mais qu'est-ce
que ça enlève aux autres rien c'est
évidemment c'est d'essayer d'ailleurs
c'est un peu ça le faisons présentement
dans une pure logique d'augmentation ça
n'enlève rien à personne
ça les a peut-être une question sur
l'enfant qui va naître sans avoir de
père mais ça d'une certaine manière
c'est c'est pas le temps c'est pas le
coeur de la démonstration
le sujet principal pour moi c'est est ce
que nous avons quelque chose à gagner à
entrer dans cette logique d'augmentation
perpétuelle qui a priori menant lève
rien à personne
mais qu'est ce que nous avons à gagner
dans cette dans cette projection de
l'homme augmenté qui à mon avis revient
à ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
c'est à dire à nous regarder nous mêmes
comme des hommes diminué et a refusé
d'habiter ces corps qui avec toutes
leurs limites sont malgré tout le lieu
de notre vie est la seule vie qui serait
à vendre
l'homme cela signifie simplement pour
terminer vous avez justement dans la pmm
a cité cette idée que quand à votre sens
il y a une forme d'infertilité il est
légitime que la médecine viennent aider
finalement par sa science parce qu'elle
peut apporter
mais là aussi on rencontre une limite
naturelle pourtant puisque 1 une femme
n'a pas pu par sa constitution physique
avoir d'enfant et celle ci pourra
pourtant être aidé donc la limite
naturelle s'il y en a certaines qui
peuvent être vécues comme injuste c'est
ça un petit peu que en quoi là ça n'est
pas de l'addition finalement c'est ce
qu'on appelle une pathologie d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui pour recourir à une pma
légalement vous devez faire reconnaître
une situation d'affaires tiré des
pathologies oui mais là la maladie fait
partie de la nature mais la maladie est
une sorte de lacunes dans ce qu'on
appelle la santé a encore une fois c'est
à dire l'equilibre ordinaire décor assez
très difficile comme vous le savez sans
doute forcément parce que c'est des
questions qui touchent aussi au droit
c'est très difficile de définir la santé
c'est une question très complexe et qui
a mobilisé beaucoup de littérature
médicale juridique et philosophique mais
il ne reste pas moins que la santé
demeure une forme de déquilibre que nous
recevons que nous produisons pas et
c'est pour rétablir ou pour préserver la
santé que le médecin intervient
aujourd'hui la tradition médicale est là
pour faire en sorte que des corps
retrouve cet équilibre naturel alors
évidemment la maladie est une anomalie
de la vie des corps qui n'est pas une
anomalie statistique c'est à dire que
quelqu'un qui ne serait jamais malade
serait au contraire une anomalie
statistique
il ne reste pas moins que ce que nous
cherchons dans la médecine c'est là le
rétablissement de la santé
et de fait quelqu'un qui dans une union
hétérosexuelle n'arrive pas à avoir
d'enfant c'est quelqu'un qui rencontre
un troubles pathologiques parce que
c'est quelque chose qui va à l'encontre
de cet équilibre naturel dont nous
savons bien que il est normalement
fécond et donc il ya quelque chose comme
une anomalie qui peut être qu'il peut
susciter l'intervention de la médecine
alors qu à l inverse
moi je suis
voilà je peux faire tout l'effort que je
veux tout seul me faire tout l'effort
qu'elle veut tout seul et jamais le
désir d'un corps ne suffit à engendrer
la vie jamais le désir de deux corps de
même sexe me suffit a engendré la vie
donc là il s'agit de faire encore une
fois tout autre chose que de réparer le
vivant il s'agit de l'augmenter c'est
une logique qui à mon avis encore une
fois nous faire entrer dans la voie
d'une frustration perpétuelle parce que
ne nous voilons pas la face lorsque la
pma aura été étendue aux couples de
femmes et aux femmes seules et à la la
la la barrière suivante
et ensuite ensuite on ne s'arrêtera pas
là le désir d'avoir un enfant en bonne
santé par exemple le désirent même
d'avoir un enfant intelligent d'avoir un
enfant qui réussit dans la vie et c'est
un désir qui est parfaitement légitime
et parfaitement respectable et on nous
dira avec tout autant de raisons
pourquoi refuserait ton à ceux qui le
souhaitent d'avoir un enfant en bonne
santé d'avoir un enfant intelligent
d'avoir un enfant qui va réussir même
pourquoi pas d'avoir un enfant qui leur
semble qu'ils aient les mêmes goûts que
ou bien d'avoir un enfant qui en quoi ce
désir là ne serait-il pas respectable et
alors nous entrons dans l'oeuvre dans la
marche d'après au fond nous ne seront
jamais satisfaits de l'état dans lequel
nous sommes
et c'est à mon avis cette incapacité à
la contemplation montant parlais tout à
l'heure
cette incapacité à recevoir la condition
humaine avec ses imperfections comme
étant notre expérience de vie et ce dans
quoi nous devons vivre cette incapacité
à nous émerveiller de ce qui est malgré
tout merveilleux
malgré tout les limites qui sont les
faits de notre de notre existence
c'est cette incapacité là qui en fait
derrière la promesse d'une utopie
constitue je crois notre notre fuite en
avant dans une forme de malheurs et de
frustration perpétuel et souvent la
rhétorique de l'égalité malheureusement
c'est aussi l'expression de cette de
cette frustration perpétuelle une
question
qui a rapport un petit peu avec les lois
de la nature mais qui me pèse
est ce que au fond vous concluez du feq
par exemple pour la procréation
il faut un spermatozoïde et un ovocyte
il faut un homme et une femme pour
élever un enfant parce que c'est une
conséquence claudie gasc parce qu'il
faut ça pour la procréation est ce que c
est ce que la famille c'est forcément un
homme et une femme
ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup sur moi je
suis pas je suis pas psychologue ou
psychiatre après je sais que je sais
c'est qu'on a reculé tout ça et on n'a
pas de recul sur ces questions ce qui me
estimates ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup
c'est de voir au fond que nous faisons
comme si l'homme était un être
susceptible d'être réformé susceptible
d'être transformée comme si nos
constructions humaines en fait ne
reposaient que sur des conventions et
des artifices immédiatement inventé on a
vu et su les dans la question de
l'écologie
on a vu que il suffisait parfois de
déplacés de tout petits paramètres pour
que des écosystèmes entiers soient
perturbées avec un écosystème c'était
une complexité infinie d'organisation du
vivant c'est vrai d'un écosystème global
c'est vrai de chaque organisme dans nos
corps aussi il suffit parfois que de
tous petits paramètres soient modifiés
pour que d'un seul coup nous ayons dû
mal à trouver notre équilibre et comment
on commence pourrait-il au fond que nous
n'appliquons pas cette prudence à ses
écosystèmes de nos vies que sont par
exemple les familles je veux dire par là
que toute la psychanalyse par exemple
nous montre à quel point au fond le
repaire du masculin et du féminin sont
structurants la construction psychique
tout la psychanalyse nous a montré à
quel point de l'inscription dans une
filiation était la condition de notre
structuration personnel alors de fait je
ne dis pas par là et encore une fois je
ne suis pas médecin et picot dans le
dire je ne dis pas par là qu'un enfant
qui manque d'un père ou d'une mère sera
forcément condamnés au malheur pour tout
sa vie bien loin de manger les enfants
du label réformes qui sont très
malheureux
bien sûr ça pour le coup ça veut rien
dire parce que si vous voulez c'est
comme ça c'est très fort c'est comme ci
comme ça il ya des gens qui ont avant
tout le tout tout tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour vivre et qui sont très
malheureux donc on peut on peut priver
tout le monde le fait que voyez vous
rendez vous initié enfin bien sûr bien
sûr mais surtout le plus important à
dire c'est que un enfant qui grandit
dans une famille où il manque un père ou
une mère n'est pas évidemment condamné à
être malo c'est le plus important bien
sûr que non bien sûr que non mais malgré
tout je crois que nous manquons
certainement aujourd'hui dans l'ordre de
nos constructions sociales dans l'ordre
de nos familles peut-être nous manquons
sans doute de cette prudence dont nous
avons manqué dans notre rapport à
l'environnement
lorsque avec un peu de l'orgueil
peut-être est sans doute un peu d'un
conséquence nous nous sommes dit que
pour que nos désirs soit satisfait et il
était possible de perturber les
équilibres naturels les plus les plus
lointains les plus complexes
alors qu'en réalité nous ne savions pas
ce à quoi nous touchons mais peut-être
quand elle ne nous ne savons pas
exactement ce à quoi nous touchons très
favorable nous sorte de principe de
précaution n'ont pas vu bien sûr va
d'ailleurs le principe de précaution
s'est imposé dans le dans notre droit
droit s'est imposé dans notre rapport à
l'environnement je crois qu'aujourd'hui
plus personne ne le conteste
sérieusement ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup
c'est le débat entre deux philosophes
allemands un philosophe qui s'appelait
anxionnat c'est un philosophe qui
s'appelait hans bloc blog qui défendent
est une sorte d'optimisme structurels en
disant il faut absolument que la
technique puisse avancer et younes qui
répondaient par la revendication d'un
pessimisme méthodologique
qu'est ce qui pourrait arriver si ce que
nous produisons dysfonctionnait il faut
se poser la question de cette prudence
nécessaire et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
nous sommes aussi devant ce débat dans
l'ordre bio le sirpa rigueur de
l'écologie l'inde est l'un des rares
défenseurs des les collines à tous ses
fans
oui il ya un aspect moi aussi que j'ai
apprécié c'est le débat autour de ce que
vous avez appelé la liquéfaction de la
politique et je vais je et en vous
écoutant et je reprends la question de
jean baptiste serre que je me dis mais
comment allez vous rendre compatible le
discours que vous tenez depuis votre
votre fonction de d'enseignant en
philosophie et de diffuseurs de passeurs
de très talentueux d'idées et puis votre
votre engagement politique parce que
alors c'est ce constat de liquéfaction
moi je crois qu'il est assez largement
imputable nous élus mais qu'il est aussi
assez largement imputable aux électeurs
je les lui à une trop fâcheuse tendance
à dire à l'électeur ce que ce dernier
souhaite entendre alors appeler ça comme
on veut
je populisme ou pas enfin peu importe
sur du changement est aussi c'est
l'électeur est absolument parce que au
fond le problème de l'élection c'est que
l'élu cherche avant tout à se faire
réélire etc
et quand cela une l'antre assez
volontiers peut-être même sans trop s'en
apercevoir dans une logique de séduction
et lorsque je veux séduire je ne suis
pas moi-même je suis prêt à mettre de
côté certaines vérités et c'est bon tu
sais ce que j'ai trouvé très gênant mois
dans le lex l'expérience la micro
expérience d'élu local que j'ai eus qui
m'a fait dire que plus jamais de jouer
des coudes pour être sur le devant de la
photographie etc enfin c'est aussi cela
la paix ce n'est pas que de la
communication
hélas la politique ou heureusement
peut-être c'est aussi cela mais ce n'est
pas que cela est donc sur 7 sur 7
liquéfaction si vous voulez vous faire
élire
quel discours pouvez vous tenir sans me
demander si vous vous voudrez ou pas
vous faire réélire ça peu importe
et puis il ya sous cette idée les
factions quand même moins dans notre
ordre politique
j'identifie des des points 2 alors de
permanence tout est relatif moi je pense
que
il n'y a pas de la vérité qu'en
démocratie on est capable de dégager
elle ne vaut qu'à un moment donné la
délibération sur le bon et le juste sur
le bien elle ne vaut qu'un instant et
cette difficulté de la vie démocratique
c'est qu'il faut remettre toujours sur
sur l'ouvragé
cette cette question de la libération
sur ce qu'il faut faire ou sur ce qu'il
conviendrait de faire mais il ya quand
même des permanences enfin on a la
faculté de droit organisée la nuit du
droit à la salle du jeu de paume il ya
peu de temps autour d'un texte d'un
texte fondateur de notre ordre politique
actuelle qui est la déclaration du 26
août 1789
voilà des éléments de permanence des
fondamentaux dans notre vie politique de
notre de notre vie sociale qui sont qui
sont sans arrêt et est régulièrement
renouvelés actualisé notamment par la
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
enfin je pensais aussi à la à cette
phrase trop connu de du guépard
il faut que tout change pour que te
reste comme avant
c'est un peu cela donc il ya ces sept
cette compatibilité entre ce que vous
dites est peut-être ce que vous êtes et
votre engagement politique qui me posent
une question importante et puis ya au
delà de la liquéfaction quand même pour
moi aussi des éléments structurants au
fond rassurant qui ne sont pas immuables
mais qui sont tout de même très ancrée
et très profondément ancré dans notre
dans la manière dont nous concevons la
vie en société
voilà c'était mes 2 mai 2 mai de
cassidian et bien sûr heureusement
d'ailleurs que nous pouvons fonder notre
vie collective sur ces institutions qui
sont instituées pour durer on connaît on
connaît cette cette formule magnifique 1
qui résume justement ce que l'état qui a
pour des finitions d'être et de rester
stats de demeurer comme un point fixe au
milieu des mouvements du monde
on connaît cette formule magnifique de
louis xiv prêté à louis xiv agonisant je
m'en vais mais l'état demeurera toujours
il ya évidemment dans le sens de l'état
dans le sens de la continuité des
institutions
une sorte de condition de notre de notre
existence collective
ce qui m'intéresse d'ailleurs c'est de
voir à quel point justement nous avons
le sentiment d'une forme de fragilité de
l'état dans ce mouvement perpétuel et à
quel point notre rhétorique politique ou
la configuration de notre débat public
mais aussi en crise en quelque sorte 7,7
ce sens delà de la continuité
au fond ce qui m'intéresse dans ce dans
ce texte ce n'est pas de défendre encore
une fois vous l'avez compris et ça ce
serait le l'occasion d'un débat
proprement politique de défendre ses
points fixes particulier vers lesquels
il me semble que nous devons nous
diriger mais ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
tenter d'agir sur la configuration même
du débat public c'est à dire un tout
petit mesure d'essayer de montrer que
nous ne pouvons pas nous contenter
d'opposer le ceux qui veulent bouger à
ceux qui veulent rester immobile et qu'
il s'agit de commencer par se poser la
question de savoir vers où nous nous
voulons nous diriger ensemble
et de ce point de vue là je suis
peut-être totalement inadapté au monde
d'aujourd'hui si c'était le sens de
votre question je crois que la politique
consiste à faire face aussi l'engagement
politique consiste à faire face à cette
possibilité comme le disait max weber
dans le
le cettex magnifique qui s'appelle le
métier la vocation de politique celui
qui celui qui peut vraiment servir dans
l'ordre politique c'est celui qui est
capable de faire face lucidement à la
possibilité du naufrage de tous ses
espoirs
et c'est vrai que ben voilà on vient
aussi débat public en essayant de
proposer quelque chose qui nous tient à
coeur
avec l'idée que peut-être effectivement
ce qu'on voudrait proposer ne sera
jamais reçu ne sera jamais compris que
peut-être d'ailleurs ce qu'on a à
proposer avec sa propre prudence et son
propre regard ne correspond pas à ce qui
est nécessaire parce que nos regards
sont faillibles qu'ils sont limités et
c'est toute la noblesse de la démocratie
telle que la décrivent et aristote que
de faire en sorte que nous pouvons nous
nous corriger les uns les autres nous
ajuster les uns par les autres dans
l'expérience du débat je crois que si
nous venions aussi à la politique avec
l'idée non pas d'imposer nos convictions
mais de pouvoir de tenter de les mettre
à l'épreuve de la contestation de
l'autre avec cet idéal très très fin
très proche de celui du savon qui
justement avec ses pairs se soumet à
leur regard pour pouvoir lui même le
cheminée et bien nous vivrions aussi une
vie politique plus sereine et plus et
plus plus paisible et sans doute aussi
plus plus plus ajustée à ce dont nous
avons besoin
peut-être que je suis complètement
inadapté au monde d'aujourd'hui mais
peut-être pas et vous le remarquez tout
à l'heure je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes très nombreux à nous dire que
nous avons besoin de retrouver un peu de
stabilité de retrouver un peu d'
équilibre peut-être que cette intuition
écologique dont on vous dit qu'elle est
partagée par tous
il importe seulement de la poussée
jusqu'à sa cohérence globale ce qui me
frappe beaucoup c'est de voir à quel
point de sun contradictoires je lisais
un numéro 2 de libé il ya quelques jours
vous pour revenir à la question de la
pma dont on parlait à l'instant
l'édito de libé 10 est enfin fini de ces
vieilleries
nous allons pouvoir vaincre par la
technique les limites de notre condition
et j'ai tout ce qu'ils voudront un
enfant pour enfin en avoir un et huit
pages plus loin il y avait un reportage
sur l'agriculture durable qui disait
font ce qu une réconciliation avec la
nature avec les équilibres naturels
je crois qu'effectivement se réconcilier
avec les équilibres naturels c'est
accepter de ne plus manger de fraises en
hiver c'est accepter aussi que tous nos
désirs ne puisse pas être satisfaits et
qu'effectivement le désir d'enfant tout
légitime qu'il soit parfois rencontrera
l'obstacle que les limites que notre
condition lui impose continueront de lui
fixer et au fond peut-être que ceux ci
et paraît aujourd'hui lointain mais vous
savez les écologistes ont été très
longtemps raillé parce qu'on les
considérait comme d'horribles
réactionnaires qui voulaient s'éclairer
à la bougie
peut-être qu'au fond dans quelques dans
quelques années quand le cas c'est ce
que j'espère parce que oui ce sont des
choses auxquelles je crois
nous nous pourrons nous dire que nous
réconcilier avec nos corps c'était aussi
peut-être la meilleure manière de
retrouver une forme de bonheur de
bonheur limiter le bonheur marqué aussi
justement par la finitude mais de bonne
heure pour temps réel parce que c'est un
bonheur qui consiste à habiter vraiment
ce monde plutôt qu'à tenter de le
détruire sujet d'une question qui fait
un peu le lien réaliser cette femme mais
et quand tu vois là où on lit partout
vous êtes le nouveau penseurs de la
droite ce qui réconcilie la philosophie
et puis votre action politique
vous prenez ça comme un compliment ou
c'est quelque chose qui vous est assez
lointain finalement parce que c'est
jamais prétendu j'ai joué ce rôle
j'essaye de me voler mon signe ce que ce
que je crois profondément c'est pour le
coup c'est ce serait mon grand point
d'accord avec emmanuel macron je crois
que les clivages du 20e siècle sont
déplacés je veux dire par là que le
xxème siècle a été marqué par le par le
leap aux thèses marxistes qui faisaient
que on était du côté soit à l'est du mur
de berlin soit à l'ouest c'est qu'au
fond le grand clivage était celui de
l'économie administrée ou de l'économie
libre et qu' à partir de là au fond tout
le reste s'en suivait pour le mur de
berlin s'est écroulé et personne ne
s'est enfui à l'est donc l'histoire a
tranché d'une certaine manière je veux
dire par là qu'aujourd'hui le sujet
n'est pas faut-il choisir la voie
totalitaires ou bien faut-il renoncer
donc nous sommes tous d'accord au fond
pour une forme de consensus sur le fait
de préserver la démocratie et l'économie
libérale on pourra se disputer sur la
nature de ce libéralisme sur la quantité
de liberté où abdou d'intervention de
l'état mais fondamentalement plus
personne ne revendique que la notion de
la nationalisation immédiate de
l'économie
c'est plus le sujet sur lequel se joue
notre débat public est donc aujourd'hui
il importe de réviser profondément nos
débats démocratiques à la lumière des
défis du 21ème siècle ne sont pas ceux
du 20e siècle
là où je suis en désaccord avec emmanuel
macron c'est que je ne crois pas à la
fin des clivages je crois pas qu'il ait
d'un côté le nouveau monde et de l'autre
côté l'ancien monde je pense que le vrai
clivage encore une fois n'est pas dans
l'opposition du nouveau et l'ancien mais
dans la question de savoir vers où nous
devons nous diriger et de ce point de
vue là c'est vrai qu'en mars
je suis soirée le mouvement oui c'est
fabuleux d'ailleurs comme slogan de ce
pont du las je vais commencer à
travailler sur seul il ya quelques
années mais l'apparition d'un mouvement
qui s'appelait en fait une confirmation
magnifique travailler avant vous aviez
commencé avant oui ce qui est ce qui me
ce qui me paraît très significatif c'est
que comme comme beaucoup de gens de ma
génération dans les années précédentes
j'ai eu du mal à savoir à quel endroit
j'habitais sur le terrain politique et
je me suis souvent sentie beaucoup plus
proche de beaucoup d'élus et d'électeurs
de gauche que de beaucoup d'élus et
d'électeurs de droite sur certains
points
il ya quelque chose qui est qui
aujourd'hui et inabouti dans la
construction de nos débats politiques et
j'espère que nous allons pouvoir rêver
non pas à la fin des clivages ce serait
la fin du dialogue démocratique et à mon
avis ce serait une catastrophe
mais à renouvellement des clivages pour
que le débat soit vraiment ajusté au
défi devant lesquelles nous sommes
placés on voit que depuis tout à l'heure
on parle beaucoup d'écologie qui est
aujourd'hui sur le terrain et plus de
politiques est plutôt classé à gauche
en même temps les idées que je défends
sur la question de la pma aujourd'hui
elles sont plus de identifié à droite
donc c'est très difficile de savoir
exactement à quel endroit
nous pouvons faire des choses et danser
dans ce petit livre je me suis beaucoup
appuyé par exemple sur martinez pas
spécialement forcément de droite
donc voilà il ya quelque chose qui
appelle une forme de reconfiguration
aujourd'hui c'est certain la très
rapidement parce qu'ils voudraient deux
minutes
c'est un petit bug gênant quand on vous
présente comme celui qui va repenser la
droite
bah c'est la voit aussi une certaine
manière que ce mouvement votre besoin
d'appartenance on a plus de pensée ou
pensent mal et que vous interveniez
justement pour lui donner un nouveau
souffle alors très rapidement alors une
question de par rapport à ce qu'en
disait tout à l'heure finalement moi je
crois que le mouvement pour le mouvement
ça n'existe jamais je crois que un être
humain agit toujours pour quelque chose
et qu'en réalité en fait c'est plutôt le
but qu'on va critiquer fait travailler
trop il ya autre chose dans la ville et
le débat n'est-il pas plutôt finalement
de de savoir si les buts que nous
poursuivons ne sont pas contradictoires
je crois que le débat véritablement là
est la question de savoir si les moyens
que nous donnons pour atteindre nos buts
sont suffisants et si il permettre de
les atteindre parce que vous parlez
beaucoup de ce mouvement et du but mais
je crois qu'en fait le vrai débat c'est
plutôt celui de l'articulation de la
cohérence entre les buts et
entre les moyens et les buts qu'une pour
suivre très rapidement parce que m non
j'ai entièrement d'accord avec vous bien
sûr je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est vrai
vous disiez il ya une fragilité de la
droite sur le terrain intellectuel mais
c'est vrai de tous les partis politiques
malgré tout je crois qu'il nous manque
aussi le sens des buts et la capacité de
les penser ensemble bien sûr que l'homme
n'agit jamais pour rien et aujourd'hui
nous nous trouvons confrontés à cette à
ce sentiment peut être de vidou de
lacunes à ce sens de l'homme qui nous
manque comme disait saint-exupéry
parce que nous avons du mal à penser les
buts de notre action collective
c'est ce qu'il nous faut faire ensemble
est effectivement vous avez tout à fait
raison de dire que il faut tenter de
retrouver cette cohérence des buts et
l'articulation des moyens avec les fins
que nous nous donnons ensemble je vous
envoie la lecture de ce livre qui fait
beaucoup qui fait débat en l'air pour la
vue demeure ccc chez grasset merci
infiniment un uncharted vézina motricité
pas le morceau et merci beaucoup
françois merci à vous merci infiniment
merci
[Musique]